let's go to our caller from the 401 area
code our friendly neighbors to the south
in Rhode Island Iced yes that is you yes
hello my name is Michael I live in
Woonsocket Rhode Island Woonsocket I
have a lot on my mind I have plenty of
questions but I got one how can we just
looking at Beacon complete political
mess it reminds me a lot of the
antebellum era like I feel like we're so
divided like how can we coexist people I
don't feel like use me I'm on I have I'm
on a spectrum so just follow me all
right
okay um like we can't even we don't even
agree on reality basically yeah yeah and
just one side it just seems they just
keep on demonize and that's to the point
like you see us as anti-american and I'm
begin to see them as anti-american and
just how can we coexist how can we this
is just ridiculous
you know you've gotten to one of the
fundamental issues that's going on right
now which is if we don't even have a
shared understanding of the most basic
truths about reality I don't know how we
work together to solve anything and
that's where we get these situations
where one party gets into power and gets
a couple of things done around the edges
getting around the obstruction of the
other party and then the situation
reverses and meanwhile it's the mass of
people that lose it's people who are
hoping to get a raise
whose wages have been stagnant for 40
years if you're in the bottom 50% of the
country it's a health care system that
still doesn't work for tons and tons of
people even people who can't afford
their premiums but it's still a terrible
system I mean you're right
I don't have an answer this is one of
the areas in which I am at least
optimistic in politics when the Democrat
yes sorry there's anything more
concerned about what the moderates think
about whether or what about the
center-right or the white working-class
would do care about know like like I am
I've done understand I'm saying they're
considered they're worried about a class
a group of voters
I won't vote for them Republicans Karen
about I don't worry that's stupor I mean
I I don't think we should write off how
certain portions of the electorate will
see the policies of Democrats I actually
think that's important and ignoring that
is how you end up with terrible
candidates that lose election so I don't
I don't I disagree with you that it's
bad to think about that but I think it
all has to happen sort of like a broader
context of understanding the world in
which a candidate is running but I I
don't think it's a bad thing for
Democrats to ask those questions I'd
like these I know and I'm even just like
we haven't quite in who thinks oh we can
work with the Republicans no we can't
work with the Republicans we can't okay
now you're talking
yes there's a difference between
considering how a white working-class
voters will see the policy of a
Democratic candidate versus these
completely out of this world these
completely out of this world ideas that
as soon as we have a Democratic
president Republicans are going to work
with us on stuff it's like no they're
not we know from experience that they're
not look at the first two years of
Barack Obama's presidency yeah like we
should have like this were like this is
my problem with the Democratic Party
there you don't have that um there was a
there's an interesting article I read
Republicans understand powers there are
they're insane abortion bills basically
an article basically they show how they
understand power there aren't power they
want to do what they want and it's gonna
do it no matter what like I only
Democrats had that's fine but we want to
have Medicare for all it so we're gonna
do it and we're going to steam roll with
it
yep basing that only only sometimes do
listen really appreciate the call great
to hear from our folks down in Rhode
Island hope to hear from you again